hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're
continuing our coverage of the 1972
World Chess Championship the match of
the century between Bobby Fischer and
buddy Spassky
we are in Game seven today Bobby Fischer
has been on a tear he started out with
two losses one of those coming from a
forfeit but since then he's won three of
the last four and the other one he did
tie so he has come back and he's up
again going into game number 7 now
birdie Spassky does have the white
pieces so Spassky is going to be looking
to power back here and even in this
series up so we'll go ahead and get into
a game number seven starts out with pawn
to e4 this was the first time but he's
basically started with pond d4 we are
used to seeing it from Bobby Fischer
although he caught us by surprise in the
last game but pawn efore from buddy
Spassky pawn c5 the Sicilian offense
Knight f3 pawn d6 upon d4 capture Knight
to f6 Knight c3 and then pawn a6 this is
the NIE Dorf defense they decided to go
with the main line with Bishop to g5
upon e six and then after f4 there's a
lot of options that Bobby Fischer could
go with and he chose the poison pawn now
this is one of the more common lines
that you'll see at the highest level
nowadays but back then there was not
nearly as much theory behind it I do
have a separate video on the poison pond
so I'm not going to get in to too much
detail on that specifically if you want
to check out that opening is under the
strategy check section on the website
but Bobby Fischer's decided to go and
play the Queen to b6 and then after
Queen to d2 decided to go ahead and take
the poison pawn here on b2 now White has
two options he does have a rook to b1
which is probably the strongest way to
go ahead and attack this he kind of went
for the less common line and that was
Knight to b3 had he gone with a more
common move of rook to b1 then we can
see Queen back here a three men start
pushing forward on the King side of the
board this somewhat plays like the Kings
gambit getting ready to get his life
screw Bishop involve
to the game castle on the kingside have
your rook here on the F file just
raining down tear on your opponents but
instead these decides to go ahead and
play a Knight to b3 the compensation
really looking to get a strong attack on
the King side and really take this queen
out of the equation Bobby fish on the
other hand knowing that he's up a pond
of material it's going to be looking to
bring his queen back here to a3 does not
want to get it trapped on the Queen side
of the board and then just trying to
chip away and keep his advantage that he
already has right now being up a pawn
bishop here to d3 I really think a buddy
Spassky in this position should be
taking here on f6 some of the
compensation he could be getting is to
go ahead and give Bobby Fischer double
pawns here after pawn takes here on f6
this King is really going to be exposed
for much of the game he's not going to
be castling on the Kings side very often
so his Kings going to be saying safely
back here maybe pawn or king to e7 but
for the rest of game Bobby Fischer has
to be somewhat conservative on how he
plays he can't overextend too much
because buddy Spassky can just attack
his King in the center of the board so I
really like that but instead we see
Bishop to d3 getting ready to castle on
the Kings side now Bishop e7 I still
think go ahead and capture here although
it's not going to be a double pawn here
on the F file I still think go ahead and
capture here decides to go ahead and
castle on the Kings side upon to h6
still think you could take here but
decided to go and bring Bishop back here
h4 and then Knight takes on e4 taking
away the second central pawn that buddy
Spassky has and then Knight takes here
on e4 Bishop takes on h4 and then pawn
pushes forward to f5 and if you kind of
look at it Bobby Fischer's doing a
really good job so far in this game he
already took the pawn here on b2 and but
he's fast he's already given up an
additional pawn if I kind of look at I
don't think he has tons of compensation
for those pawns that he's given up now
if we look at this position right here
he does have the option to be a little
bit tricky and play Bishop to b5 now
this is tricky he does actually play
this a little bit later so I think
was on his radar I'm not sure why he
didn't play it right away but if the
pond were to take all of a sudden I
could take him up here on d6 the king is
forced to move let's say King e7 then
Knight back here b5 which probably be
done regardless of what Blackwood did
with his King
but now the Queen's forced to move all
of a sudden the Queen come up here to d6
check things get pretty interesting the
knight can come up here c7 a little bit
later so all in all I think this would
have been a little bit better play than
just playing pawn to f5 Bobby Fischer
does take here on f5 and after this
exchange then but these pesky decides to
go ahead and play Bishop here to b5
after the take here night up here d6
attacking the king and then after the
King to f8 then the Knights going to
come up here and take on c8 night here
to c6 just getting this not involved
into the game also attacking the knight
to the knight is forced to move back
here and then after rook to d8 just
pinning down the knight to the queen
would you see the knight take here on a
b5 saying hey you can go ahead and take
my queen I'll go ahead and take your
queen right back Bobby Fischer not
looking to give up his Queen right away
so Queen back here to e7 Bob Fisher is
up and material and he has a pretty good
position so there's no real reason to
get rid of his most powerful piece on
board Queen to f4 just centralizing that
Queen a little bit upon to a g6
solidifying at this pawn chain that he
has since this pond was under attack
from the Queen upon up here to a4 and it
did have some options here I think he
could also tried g3 Bishop back here to
g5 forcing the Queen to move Queen here
to c4 I think this is fine as well he
was trying to just for something on the
Queen side of the board so he plays pawn
to a4 a now Bishop here g5 a queen back
here c4 as we talked about it's these
small little nuances throughout the game
where it could have drastically changed
how things go so instead of having a
pawn up here in g3 he is forcing a
little bit on
the queenside with ponzu a for now
Bishop down here III check and it's a
just nice little square it's going to be
very difficult for but he's fast key to
really force this Bishop away later on
Bobby Fischer is going to be looking to
play pawn to f4 just solidifying the
pressure that he has right here so nice
little square from Bobby Fischer King to
H 1 just putting in the corner of the
board and then pawn to f4 s we talked
about nice little outpost for the bishop
here on e3 pawn to g3 trying to break
that up but pawn to g5 pretty much says
hey I can just replace that if I need to
they can always just get defense I think
playing rook over here to g8 is going to
be very good for Bobby Fischer can
easily get his Queen involved to defend
if he needs to rook over here to e1 and
then Queen to be for it and queen of e4
is kind of that just weird move to me
Bobby Fischer is definitely up in this
game I think he's dominating in some
respect I just think he has a much
better position he's up in material he's
putting a lot of pressure on his
opponent he has a nice little outpost
with his bishop right here very very
aggressive I think playing rook here to
GA is the best play he wants to keep all
this very powerful pieces on board we
could see Knight c3 Knight e5 just
starting to swing all the material onto
the King side of the board Queen to b4
just says hey I'm kind of tapping out
here I can't find a good line and so I
don't want to mess this up I have a one
game advantage I'm playing the black
pieces if I can come out here with a
drawl that's fine to me so I do think
that he could have had a much better in
game if he did not play Queen to b4 but
decide to go and give up that Queen
Knight ticking here on b4 and then work
up here e to King g7 rook or Knight a5
pawn b6 just forcing the knight to move
now it's attacking the pawn and we do
see this song and dance a little bit on
the Queen side of the board both sides
kind of attacking the the pawns here but
it's fast key doing a nice job using
the nights together just attacking all
the available material and then forcing
the the pawns up a little bit to protect
the night so all nobody's fast he has
done a good job he failed miserably I
think at the beginning to have any sort
of compensation for the two pawns he
gave up he did battle back to be down
only one pawn in material he did get
Bobby Fischer's queen off the board
and now he's even staging a little
attack of his own on the Queen side rook
up here to f3 forcing the knight back
the night comes back here takes on c4 so
gobbling up some pawns on board pawn
takes here on f4 pawn down here a g4
rook over here at d3 so but he's
basically doing a good job of
controlling the center of the board with
his rooks pawn h5 just a little defying
the pawn chain a little bit pawn to h3
just trying to break this up now that
over here to a5 and you have probably
heard a knight on the rim is dim I
definitely think it holds true here I'm
not sure why Bobby Fischer decided to go
and play his Knight over here on a5
there early on to the game it's not that
crazy that the Knights gonna easily be
able to get back into the game but every
move in the in game is very very vital
so to play it over here this is not the
outpost you're kind of going for yes
he's trying to just trade off Knights
here but all in all it's just not doing
too much on board and buddy Spassky says
yeah we're not even going to play that
game I'm gonna go and play Knight here
to d6 and then after the exchange here
knight on d6 rook down here c1 King up
here g2 and then Knight back here to c4
so Bobby Fischer
somewhat wasted and move trying to get
all cute and fancy over here but just
wasn't wasn't really that great of a
move so Knight back here to see for
trying to get it back into the game that
up here EA check King down here g6 pawn
up here h4 but he's fast he's starting
to put a lot of pressure on his opponent
as far as the the strongest attack white
definitely now has a much better attack
going on a Bobby Fischer his rook over
here on h8 is not anywhere close to
the action his rooks aren't playing
together at all
the king is pretty safe right now
compared to Bobby Fischer's King here on
g6 especially after rook up here east
six getting ready to play rook takes
here on f6 check being protected by this
knight right here so the tide to turn
quite a bit and Bobby Fischer is
somewhat of a pickle right now trying to
get out of this he is up and material
but as far as position wise he
definitely does not have the best
position rook here to see to check King
back here g1 now King here to f5 Knight
g7 check King down here taking on f4 we
do you see rook to d4 check and then
Knight f5 check and then after that we
see the rook down here to e4 and Bobby
Fischer is forced to do a repetitive
check he looks at it and says yeah I'm
up two pawns in material but you
actually have a mating threat on board
and so Bobby Fischer said hey I got to
draw this game out because I may lose so
after this we did see a draw on board so
all in all Bobby Fischer probably had
the win and he would had a just dominant
lead going up two games even with the
black pieces played the poison pond
extremely well but all-in-all was not
able to turn that advantage into a
victory a lot of people always ask you
know how this could have continued if
there was a mistake I say King G 1 and
then rook to g8 just from a random move
from Bobby Fischer that was not the
repetitive check we could have seen rook
f4 check forcing the King back here e2
and then night down here g3 check and
then a few moves later we could have
mates on board there's no way for Bobby
Fischer to get around this so he
recognized it went for the perpetual
check and there was a draw so going into
game 8 Bobby Fischer will be having the
white pieces he'll be looking to get
back on track he still has that one game
advantage to all in all this is not
bad for bobby fisher' even when he's
playing not as best at the endgame he's
still getting pretty good results so
game seven is in the bag hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video and I'll see you
guys in game eight thanks for watching